[Music]
the following program contains the
opinions of its host and guests not
those of this network the opinions
expressed are for non-commercial
informational purposes only listeners
are cautioned not to rely on program
content to treat or prevent disease but
are advised to consult with a licensed
health care professional where they live
for diagnosis and treatment of disease
and now the superstar of alternative
health and purveyor of medical truth dr.
Joel Wallach
[Music]
hello and welcome to death dollars don't
lie dr. Joel Wallach your host a
veterinarian and position and I'm here
for kids and baby boomers and seniors
who don't want to die 75.5 like their
parents or grandparents I'm here for
kids and baby boomers and seniors who
don't want to be sick and miserable
class 15 to 20 years that are like like
their parents and grandparents I am a
conservative a lot of people say I treat
them like dogs but no health challenge
when asked about a health challenge of a
friend or what want to work me I want to
talk about medical politics at home
based business opportunity it was it
called toll-free one triple eight three
seven nine two five five two and as
toll-free one triple eight three seven
nine two five five two today we have a
couple extra lines open on the priority
line that's eight three one six eight
five ten eighty priority line is eight
three one six eight five ten eighty and
I want to reiterate today that is very
scary the medical system continues to
fail the American public we ranked 43rd
in the world when it comes to longevity
there's 42 other countries who live on
during those yet we spend more money
each year for health care than all the
other 206 nations combined in the United
Nations our children of the first
Americans that were slated to not live
as well as your parents that's a scary
one there right our children be the
first American slated to not live as
long as a parent or gonna die before you
do
okay and of course metal doctors
according Johns Hopkins Medical School
very very famous well-respected said
that the number three cause of death in
America is medical doctors mistakes
certain 51,000 Americans are killed each
year by medical mistakes everybody gets
a walk no ocean tickets are issued and
nobody does anything what would happen
if Iran or North Korea where they send
over an intercontinental ballistic
missile with biological or nuclear
chemical weapons so two hundred fifty
one thousand people envy war wouldn't it
well here's one trait it does it every
year in the workplace nobody goes to
jail
well then also the number one cause of
death in America is agreed upon good
medical treatments we're talking about
and this is from a combination of the
Institute of Medicine the Center for
Disease Control and the American Medical
Association came out and I believe it
was
mm 2012 she doesn't end something like
that and said there is a front-page
story and many newspapers across the
United States
and said that number one cause of death
is a read upon proper medical treatments
a kill in turn in fact 15 million
Americans each year in hospitals and
clinics they kill Internet 15 million
Americans each year in houses and
clinics now let's see here also the cost
of this failed treatment is just
skyrocketing right now some states there
is no insurance providers you can't buy
insurance outsiders to some states
there's only one insurance provider you
have no choice they charge six thousand
dollars for the first deductible so
people may have insurance but they can't
use it because they can't afford the six
thousand dollars deductible ok so one
ask you to do is contact your young
genius so she and say look I need some
other options here I need to know what I
can do for myself for prevention
preventive medicine I also need to know
what I can do for myself I have diabetes
high blood pressure try to macular
degeneration so on and so I want you to
ask your don't give you the associate
for the book epigenetics the death of
the genetic 30 D transmission the book
in mortality goes into the top 20
longevity cultures according to their
National Geographic and what they do
they have 40 times 100 olds we do they
have 100 for 250 we only have one for
10,000 okay and rarest ventures goes
into all the known diseases are caused
by mineral deficiencies so that's
epigenetics immortality and railroads
ventures also we have a CD and a DVD
dead doctors don't like CD out it's
really good it's kind of um which I say
the same caliber is dead doctors don't
lie from a totally different direction
and it's just going crazy who is a beta
in New York a radio interview it's
called a stick of butter a day keeps the
doctor away stick of butter day keeps
the doctor away and of course we have
another CD called public enemy number
one so I urge you to contact us or
associate get ahold of the books
epigenetics and mortality and rivers
get a hold of the CDs dead doctors don't
lie and the DVD doesn't like the CD is
stick of butter a day keeps the doctor
wait and also public enemy number one
now the basic sort of prevention here
you want to take preventive medicine
right just like you put on your car but
rent it from burning up you don't put
dirt from Texas in your car and hope
there's oil and you click real well what
we have is we call the healthy start
pack put one of those 400 pounds of body
weight in your body and there's your
body all the 90 essential nutrients and
needs to support promote maintenance
repair it supports your body his ability
to defend itself maximize your jetty
potential for longevity and health and
strength and speed and intelligence and
so on and so that's one healthy start
pack 400 pounds of body weight and again
we're talking about supportive and
preventative health but if you have a
problem like type 2 diabetes we have a
program we call the healthy blood sugar
packed and you just take your fasting
for every mind before you medicate
yourself like you always do an egg your
blood sugar drops it will you just
you're meditation or doctors want you to
do get your blood sugar down well 140
weeks in a row without medication guess
what your doctors gonna say well let me
take about the pressure gosh in 78 you
didn't take your medicine today no let's
try going a couple Eastside your
medication well you've already been
doing it for three weeks okay it's
amazing what you can do because there's
no genetic diseases there was a false
theory you know there's thousands of
false medical theories every century in
the 20th century 21st century are
different well the biggest false
theories the old theories and medicine
is the genetics bad genes cause disease
that's absolute nonsense it's called
epigenetics
okay if your genes DNA RNA and telomeres
don't have the Roman trills to do their
job they can't do their jobs
Wow what a concept first inkling of the
concept of epigenetics in the book
there's been cured there's my famous
duck experiment you need to read that
one okay of course it's in the book
resin cures actually has pictures and so
forth it'll just blow your mind okay
you don't have the nutrient to have the
best genes in the world you don't have a
nutrient jeez can't do their job they
can't
anything without the wrong trail stick
with us when advance more truth justice
in the young dirty way I'm dead you're
listening to dead doctors don't lie of
the CBS radio network with your host dr.
Joel Wallach you've ever had difficulty
getting into the show today is your day
as we do have a couple of open lights
call us on the priority life eight three
one six eight five one zero eight zero
that's eight three one six eight five
1080 lines open
[Music]
aromatherapy oils have been prized by
ancient cultures for thousands of years
youngevity x' ancient legacy true
aromatherapy is no exception
essential oils are the fragrant life
essence from plants that are gently
removed through the process of steam
distillation youngevity ancient legacy
essential oils are of the purest
concentrations from the most respected
and ethical distillers worldwide many
ancient legacy oils come directly from
families in the east
which have been distilling essential
oils for over 100 years
keep ancient legacies tea tree oil in
your medicine chests for first aid tea
tree oil is great for soothing the
itching and stinging associated with
insect bites burns scrapes and other
skin irritations it's also effective as
an antiseptic to learn more about
aromatherapy and essential oils contact
your local youngevity associate today
hey don't forget to ask about business
opportunities hey if you're like me your
life is hectic you don't know where
you're gonna be next between kids and
family and in-laws and work and traffic
and everything else that's driving me
crazy right now
my wife is insane I bet your wife's
insane as well when do we have time to
get every single nutrient we need to be
healthy when well I've got a tip for you
take a product called pollen burst it's
so simple even I can do it all you have
to do is open the package pour it in
water mix it up and bam you're ready to
go it tastes great it's not one of those
medicine tasting things it tastes great
low in calories helps curb your appetite
gives you natural energy that doesn't
let you crash gives you your vitamins
minerals nutrients everything from the
plant world and I gotta tell you for a
busy person like me or a busy person
like you we need simple we need good
poem verses your answer tastes great try
it and you'll feel better call your
local youngevity distributor to find out
how pollen burst can make you feel
better
ahead don't forget to ask about
home-based business opportunities
[Music]
we're back with dead EBS radio network
dr. Joel Wallach you're young giving
thanks you say we do have lines open
call toll-free one two three seven nine
two five five sugan that's toll-free one
triple eight three seven nine two five
five two we also have some open priority
lines eight three one six eight five ten
eighty that's priority lines 831 685
1080 I really want to talk a little bit
about CD out called a stick of butter
day keeps the doctor away not an apple a
day keeps the doctor when to stick of
butter day keeps the doctor away and
what goes into or failed medical
theories including the second biggest
one next to genetics is of course the
old theory is that cholesterol and
saturated fat cause cardiovascular
disease and large arteries and flattens
arteries also so heart attacks strokes
no no no no that was all a hoax there's
a sales program to sell Crisco by
Procter & Gamble okay and of course a
guide to name of Ancel keys a medical
doctor actually on the board of Procter
& Gamble and also on the board of
American Heart Association poker to deal
by which Procter & Gamble gave the
American Heart Association 1.7 million
dollars endorsed Crisco is a healthier
way to eat and of course rest is history
we now have a huge huge problem because
by getting everybody on a cholesterol
deficient diet and giving them statin
drugs to lower cholesterol we have
Alzheimer's disease
edie low t menopause at age 30 and real
exhaustion oh yeah Altamira disease
actually years ago with zero didn't have
it eaten by another name today's number
four cause of death of Americans get a
hold of a CD a stick of butter day keeps
doctor way learn how to protect yourself
and your family okay Doug I thought we
talked a bit about these
over-the-counter and prescription
heartburn medications as I've got a CBS
news story here headline heart bird
drugs a lake two recurring superbug
infections say patients who take certain
heartburn medications may be more likely
to suffer recurrent bouts of superbug
infection
these are the proton pump inhibitors
such as prilosec prevacid and nexium or
the h2 blockers such as an intact pepcid
aunt agatha and they are late to a 50%
increased risk of developing multiple
Clostridium difficile infections said he
did not prove that the infections that
were actually caused by the drugs but
c-diff was an association there they say
c-diff can cause diarrhea and
life-threatening inflammation of the
colon about half a million people get
sick from c-diff every year in recent
years the infectious have become more
common more severe and more difficult to
treat gastric acid suppression Mukesh
medications are commonly prescribed and
consumed over-the-counter for gastric
reflux disease or GERD peptic ulcer
disease or functional dyspepsia and
sometimes prescribed for unnecessary
indications which leads to overuse of
these medications according to the lead
researcher here doctors say say he'll
Kahana
an assistant professor of medicine at
the Mayo Clinic's division of
Gastroenterology in hematology and they
go on to say recurrent c-diff infection
is a major problem with the risk as high
as 50 to 60 percent of people having had
at least three or more infections common
it commonly affects older adults in
hospitals or long-term care facilities
however recent studies have showed an
increased rate of infections in younger
and healthier individuals without a
history of antibiotic use or exposure to
healthcare facilities they have
speculated that the suppression of
stomach acid might affect the bacteria
living to the gut in these people
leaving them the door open for CTF
infection also possible that taking
these acid suppressors may be that the
people who are taking them are not as in
the good of health this was all
published in the journal of the jam is
America internal medicine they looked at
set 16 studies in more than 7700
patients with c-diff among these about
20% developed recurrent infections
researchers found that 22% of patients
taking acid suppressers experienced
recurrence see diff infections compared
to 17% not taking the drug so there you
go yet another
not to take those and not one mention
taking something like ultimate enzymes
or you know nightly essence to help keep
burning oil or even peppermint oil yeah
and so we deserve we deserve a flourish
there because I've been talking for
thirty years about there is no such
thing as the abscess reflux it's really
should be called lack of acid reflux you
need to salt your food which is salt is
a raw material to make stomach acid you
can't absorb b12 because intrinsic
factor won't work to absorb b12 if you
don't have stomach acid you can't digest
proteins into amino acid so the pepsin
won't work in a neutral environment oh
yeah
and of course you need ants on your
stomach to keep it sterile so seed if an
e.coli another bacteria needs won't grow
in there you won't have reflux and GERD
of anytime wow yeah don't forget
welcome to the enzyme and peppermint oil
you're listening to dead doctors don't
lie are the CBS Radio Network we do have
some open lines call the priority line
at eight three one six eight five one
zero eight zero that's eight three one
six eight five 1080 lines open
[Music]
with those aches and pains in your knees
elbows hands shoulders and back crop up
reach for youngevity z' CM cream put CM
cream on a q-tip and put it in your ear
canal for relief from headaches and
sinus pressure a topical temporary
relief from minor aches and pains of
muscles and joints associated with
strains sprains and simple back aches
why take aspirin or non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs that can cause
stomach bleeding and liver damage
just apply CM cream liberally to the
affected areas and within 20 minutes or
so you'll have relief from those nagging
minor aches and pains you'll feel better
for up to 4 to 5 hours so the next time
you have a key joints or muscles do what
I do reach for CM cream for relief and
for systemic relief reach for CM plus
capsules if you'd like to learn more
about nutritional supplementation call
your local youngevity associate and
don't forget to ask about home-based
business opportunities hello Judy
Deville vez here if I could only afford
to get one product out of everything
that product would be the ultimate
classic it has the vitamins the minerals
the bio flavonoids it even has grapeseed
extract the one product that would give
you just about everything under the Sun
you would need for a perfect nutritional
program would be the ultimate classic by
the way people that are on the go it's
very very hard to take the liquids with
them when they go on their trip to get
their supplements in everyday well you
know something you can use the ultimate
daily tablets and the mineral capsules
when I'm going on a trip if I have
enough room I just take the two bottles
with me if not just use a little baggie
and take a couple of daily doses with
you it's very simple it's very easy
there's no mess no fuss no refrigeration
just take your capsules take your
tablets and you're finished for the day
to order these products call your local
youngevity distributor today you've
listened to position and veterinarian
dr. Joel Wallach helped many people on
the dead doctors dov'è talk radio
program you've also heard hundreds of
people tell how dr. Wallach and
youngevity products have changed their
lives
if you're now convinced
dr. Wallach is on to something and you
want to try your Japanese premium
quality products for yourself we could
connect you with the distributor that
serves your local area simply call our
special helpline voicemail at three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address and
we'll see to it that the right person
contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't wanna
CBS Radio Network dr. Joel Wallach here
for youngevity 95 to say we do have
lines open give us a call toll-free one
two blade three seven nine two five five
two again as toll-free one triple eight
three seven nine two five five two and
if you're gonna do the youngevity
business as a business I urge you to get
ahold of that trilogy of books let's
play doctor
that's the herbal doctor passport roma
therapy and learn how to deal with over
900 different diseases using vitamins
and minerals and trace minerals and rare
earths amino acids fatty has herbs
aromatherapy Oh the trilogy votes let's
play dr. lispy herbal dogs on the
passport roma therapy no yeah don't
forget if you haven't run a business
before you also get wall street for kids
learn how to be profitable learn how to
get the same tax rates at billiards yet
we don't want to take away their tax
rate we want to get them you only get
them if you have your own business you
can't get the tax breaks if you are an
employee you must have your own business
don't quit your job you just do the
young giving things a hard time in the
beginning and then you make decisions
later on as you grow all right let's
head to Paris California and
michelerogge with dr. Wallach well
Michelle you're on the air my mom has a
few issues and I just want to know maybe
you could help her okay tell me about
mom our first problem is a fib okay
she's had that for a while now okay
anything else yes same the second one
last cellulitis in early she's on her
second round of antibiotics okay what
else you got you got any high blood
pressure diabetes arthritis high blood
pressure
[Music]
tinnitus it nothing going on there
Anthony any dry skin eczema dermatitis
uh
well on her lane she's active cellulitis
in her leg
okay looks like okay and it looks like
blisters it could be called what we used
to call impetigo which is a form of
eczema okay and but it's not unusual for
doctors and misdiagnosis especially
younger doctors and then anything with
respiratory stuff any COPD asthma
bronchitis no okay good all right let's
see what is your mom wait she is very
heavy
she way 353 she's like five okay I said
I'd like to see a lady weigh 160 so she
needs to lose about what 210 210 pounds
baby okay Charmaine yeah we've been
dealing with a lot of people who need to
lose two three four hundred pounds lose
210 pounds she's um
five foot seven she has habit pressure
she got some skin stuff going on and
cellulitis she has a pill and of course
doctors treat fib 4 as a heart thing
what's really going on with her ap it's
a mechanical problem she's lost her
cartilage and her vertebrae and the
nerve that controls the heartbeat is
getting squeezed very good you get an A+
okay so what would you give this gal
with a tip that I would pressure are
tries to only kind of thing so we got to
run to that message moment hang on I
will be back with you in the cell and
they'll give her a diet we'll give her a
supplement program including how to lose
that you're listening to dead doctors
don't lie on the CBS radio network with
your host dr. Joel Wallach if you'd like
to talk to dr. Wallach call between do
dead work Pacific at eight three one six
eight five one zero eight zero toll-free
8 8 8 3 7 9 2 5 5 2
[Music]
you've listed a physician and
veterinarian dr. Joel Wallach helped
many people on the dead doctors doe by
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr. Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr. Wallach is on to something and you
want to try your Japanese premium
quality products for yourself we could
connect you with a distributor that
serves your local area simply call our
special helpline voicemail at three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call right down and leave your
name telephone number or email address
and we'll see to it that the right
person contact you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
3463 hi this dr. Joel Wallach your host
of dead doctors don't lie if you're
interested in a colon cleanse blood
cleanse liver cleanse in the classical
herbal way you want to ask your
youngevity associate for herbal
rainforest herbal rainforest has 16
herbs 16 cleansing herbs classic
cleansing herbs and 77 plant minerals
that's right and these are all organic
it doesn't get any better than that
and your busy day and you're around all
these toxins out there in your workplace
on the way home going to work in your
food in the air in the water you need
herbal rainforest I guarantee it it will
give you a cleanse you can control the
dose it's a liquid it tastes good it
doesn't get any better than this a colon
that's happy makes you happy
nothing better than a happy : herbal
rainforest clean it out for more
information on this product or others
you've heard about of the Dead doctors
don't lie radio program call your local
youngevity associate today and don't
forget to ask about home-based business
opportunities greetings everyone
Judy Deville bus here what do you think
of when you hear the words tangy
tangerine well I think like a sweet
tangy tasting something well what I'm
referring to is the ultimate tangy
Shereen it's a fantastic product it has
everything you need and a great benefit
is it's very very delicious it's very
easy to drink I've suggested it even to
youngsters even children like it even
little guys even little girls they come
right into my office their parents can't
get them to take those chewables and
besides that they're not as good as
tangy tangerine and I give them a little
taste of that and you know something
they're pleased as punch so if it's good
for a child and it tastes delicious why
not you there's no excuse not to take a
vitamin when it tastes as good as that
does so how about it tangy tangerine
should be the answer to all of your
nutritional program problems for more
information or to order call your
youngevity distributor today and don't
forget to ask about youngevity
home-based business opportunities this
is the CBS Radio Network Network
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't mine
as easy as Raven Network dr. Joel
Wallach your um duty Knights laughter
Sayed we do have lines open give us a
call toll free one to believe in as
toll-free one triple eight three seven
nine two five five two and if you want
to live to be well beyond 100
chronologic
2839 1,400 1,500 1,600 1,700 1,800
ninety two hundred plus well being
biologically 30 40 50 contact or young
give you associate and ask for the books
epigenetics the death of the j3z
transmission the book immortality and
the book rares in cures get a hold of
the CD a stick of butter day keeps the
doctor wait and learn how to add 25 to
50 health of years to your life it's
amazing what you can do don't depend on
everything from the doctors of
government you got to take some control
here again that's the books epigenetics
and mortality rivers been cures does he
need a stick of butter day kids a doctor
way and add 25 to 50 healthy or it's
your life okay Douglas go right back to
California and Michelle and sharp let's
first talk about the diet we need to
reduce inflammation here we need to
increase absorption efficiency and we
need to lower some calories so what
would you do for diet wise for
Michelle's mom well I would suggest that
you get on a gluten-free diet because
you're able when you have a gluten
intolerance you're able to absorb sugar
but not nutrients you're exactly right
they're unique plus and so she obviously
has a gluten problem no matter how you
look at it so no wheat barley rye oats
and then she needs to obviously take
supplements and at her weight
technically she would need four I would
get her the well healthy green and heart
pack and then I would add to it a bunch
of stuff let's slow down for a minute
here okay you're exactly right we got to
get rid of all the bags there's no fried
foods no processed meats of nitrates and
nitrites no oil I love all coconut all
margins and so forth television cooking
oils no gluten no wheat bread around
oats as you said they help reduce the
inflammation this is going to support
efficiency and
option and also have produced challenge
we have people who just got on a
gluten-free diet in the supplements and
they've lost over 300 pounds right yes
absolutely yeah and so on then you're
exactly right and of course we kind of
split it up she needs to lose and see
her she need to lose about two hundred
and ten pounds I would go ahead and have
her take oh she could take the two
healthy Banner hard packs but also since
she weighs almost 400 pounds
she had their banner hard packs I would
also throw in two healthy bone and joint
packs ok ain't kind of do it that way
and that will help support maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue this between the
vertebrae you're exactly right
it's not a hard problem when you have a
tip and all those doctors will run up at
500 I have five hundred thousand dollar
bill selling pacemakers and
defibrillators or do ablations of the
retro versions and do a heart transplant
it's really a back problem as you say
char so a minimum of 20 of the blue gel
council today to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrae particularly
in this case don't make some bonus sell
and then what would you do to support
healthy blood pressure I would get
around the ultimate daily classic and
the niacin plus okay very very good yeah
and again there's an almost 400 pounds
she should take three and the ultimate
daily classic bottles a month over the
daily classic bowels a month I would
never take for those three times a day
be 12 a day that's going to support mode
healthy blood pressures healthy blood
flow through obstructed arteries and
let's see here what would you answer
this they have or lose that 207 pounds
Sorella
Rev very good yeah Rev it's an acronym
rev re V
and I'd get two bottles a month never
put two robbers will not drop of two
drivers will under her tongue before
each meal one 30 minutes for the meal
1:15 is for the meal that have drug for
all issues then call us have you
belt letters and all her weight for
blood pressure or a tip he's doing a
Milwaukee lady speedy and in fact they
didn't doctors don't live for these
messages and that does open a line call
us toll-free 8 8 8 3 7 9 2 5 5 2 that's
triple a 372 55 two lines open
[Music]
[Applause]
you've listed a physician and
veterinarian dr. Joel Wallach helped
many people on the dead doctors dovey
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr. Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr. Wallach is on to something and you
want to try youngevity premium quality
products for yourself we could connect
you with a distributor that serves your
local area simply call our special
helpline voicemail at three one three
four four four 3463
that's three one three four four four
three four six three call right now and
leave your name telephone number or
email address and we'll see to it that
the right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
I am Judy de vil bus here I am speaking
to you again I just wanted to tell you
that recently I started drinking the way
shakes again the chocolate way shake and
you need to remember the way shake isn't
just for losing weight it's a fantastic
place to get your great protein and if
you're trying to gain weight you can
take it along with your meals and the
best part is if you want to just have a
great protein shake do like I do put it
over ice stir it up and you can sip on
it
for twenty minutes to an hour I'd do it
every single day I absolutely love it
you need to get back to it too it's
really good for you and it makes not fat
but it makes muscle after you workout
and you can also mix it up in a blender
with an egg and you have the most
incredible health protein shake or mix
it with a little water stir it up and
you have a little pudding and who
doesn't like pudding for more
information or to order call your
youngevity distributor today and don't
forget to ask about youngevity
home-based business opportunities
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors no line of
EBS radio network dr. Joel Wallach here
for you 95 to state we do have lines
open there's a call toll-free one triple
eight three seven nine two five five so
again that's toll-free one triple eight
three seven nine two five five two and
if you need to lose 10 25 50 75 100
pounds or more on tachyon you associate
and ask for the books Hell's Kitchen ask
for a free copy of the CD by the same
tile Hell's Kitchen over both energy
crisis learn about the keto dot it'll
hold of the keto caramel bar Neal bar
the keto caramel meal replace or shake
and learn through these books at being
overweight and obese is not due to lack
of extras as you too much it's actually
due to a nutritional deficiency and
don't forget you want to get on the
healthy weight loss pack and get the rev
and so of course and you'll lose a half
a pound of tude and pounds a day and
imagination will never gain the weight
back as long as you stay on your 90 for
Life program ok let's go to let's go to
Broken Arrow Oklahoma and Patti you're
odd with dr. Wallach Patti you're on the
air and he did blood work and I got the
results back a couple of days ago and
everything was perfectly fine - the
triglycerides and the cholesterol they
were both high or moderately noble okay
stop right there tell me the numbers
okay the triglyceride with 239 and the
cholesterol with 241 okay and how much
you a highway 148 148 okay how tall are
you 5 you okay yeah 5 - you're probably
30 pounds overweight maybe okay any
other issues any skin problems ecumene
dermatitis crisis or rosacea I've got
some spots on my arms you know with yes
okay so let's call it eczema for
response what spot eczema okay
what about any hits your respiratory
problems no okay what about Bob Holmes
diverticulitis or bowel syndrome colitis
floating they say that I had a
colonoscopy a long time ago and they
says I had died perfectly and I throw
had any problems or anything
okay diverticulitis all right do you
have children
I've never I have adopted my son so I
haven't really happened okay no
biological children okay all right let's
see here so all right and do you drink
soft drinks every once in a while I'm
going to strand pretty much on straight
water I'm doing water okay good
you eat donuts or anything like that I
have in the past because I joined with
you guys a few months ago okay okay the
reason I'm asking that is when you have
your triglycerides are elevated a little
bit I'd like to see them down a little
bit your cholesterol is right where I
like to see I like to see cholesterol
between 225 and 325 kind of thing so 240
one's good of course the failed theory
with the medical system is that
cholesterol causes plaque in your
arteries and heart attacks and strokes
heck how so nonsense of course did they
try to put John Stanton drugs now he
wanted to put me on Lippert all and I
told him that I was going to do yeah I
saw him I don't like the side effects
I'm going natural I actually was trying
to tell him about youngevity he needs to
be a doctor but of that right off that's
how I feel like evidence there short
time because this lowered my blood
pressure I had high blood pressure I
took care of my mom and I've been
through a lot but anyway it's gotten it
down and everything thank you okay so
here charmagne yeah it sounds like
Patty's on the right track she's been
with youngevity for a couple of months
and their blood pressures coming down
still like this year we're gonna try
glycerides a little bit but it's not too
high cholesterol is about right but she
has diverticulitis what does that mean
to you she probably has a gluten
intolerance
yeah she has some eggs most so I would
say guarantee she's got a gluten problem
eczema and these little spots in her
arms and and diverticulitis and so in
addition to get rid all the bad stuff
the fried foods processed meats are
awesome and
gluten so forth wheat by the Rhinos and
what would you do her for her for this
blood pressure I'd like to see it come
down a little faster and deal with the
triglyceride what would you do for her
well whatever she's taking I just add
the ultimate daily classic and the
niacin flush okay very good
exactly right thank you Charmaine and
Patty am at 148 pounds I'd like to see
have three of those ultimate daily
classic tablets a breakfast and dinner
those two bottles a month and they're
gonna support a healthy blood pressure
and healthy blood flow to obstructed
arteries and then of course the
triglycerides I want to get all the
sugar out of your life and no table
sugar sugar for your coffee sweet tea
those kind of things you need to get rid
of all that kind of stuff sugar is one
of the worst possible things or plaque
in your arteries that little extra
weight and for the triglycerides and so
that will help get rid of sweet tea jams
and jellies and think about any place
you know desserts for myself I like
these no sugar added yogurts and stuff
like that for dessert or we like to make
our own ice cream when I'm on the road I
will eat some ice cream but I like to
get the ice cream is designed for
diabetics and so I was asking if you
have this ice cream for diabetics I said
well yeah well that's what I want
hi sugar I certainly don't want the ones
with cookies and cream in it because
that's got gluten in sugar okay but
sounds like you're on the right track
and Charmaine is exactly correct
if those two bottles of the ultimate
daily classic Campbell is support
healthy blood pressure and healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries and really
be tight I'm getting rid of sugar out of
your life because that seems to be your
problem here as well as the gluten and
it's amazing you get off of gluten your
body will heal itself because gluten
will actually cause a contact enteritis
which has interpreted in certain
locations as diverticulitis another
location is at and the tightest and so
on so give us a call every couple of two
weeks if you would please Patti bring us
up today we'll watch it through this
okay Douglas good colleagues let's head
to Virginia and Kathleen Jerrod with dr.
Wallach okay Kathleen you're on the air
yes hi dr. Wallach I started the
youngevity program
two and a half years ago and I must say
the when I was a good girl and stayed
off of both my glutens I lost weight and
the eczema disappeared I had not really
involved it with eczema I I do not take
the double portion that you started me
on any longer it was a bit too expensive
but I but I am currently taking the
healthy body heart and brain but I I
have one I'm not a double like you
originally started me on what do you
know I'm 155 I could wait even I came
down from about 165 five five four I'm
73 and I recently also received my
report here from my blood work and my
problem has usually been high blood
pressure which is still kind of high
because I have not been a good girl with
my gluten-free diet so I think that that
has really looking at me but my HDL is
50 my triglycerides are 58 my
cholesterol is 295 which my doctor kind
of yelled at me and well than firing my
HDL is 115 my LDL is 1 6 8 okay so the
13-7 age so you're 268 total cholesterol
that's fine
268 cholesterol is fine okay and the
triglycerides at 58 is very good
okay stand away from the sugar okay and
the see here yeah so
you're not in bad shape when it comes to
cholesterol except when you have the LDL
high like that it means you're eating a
lot of things that are causing oxidation
you know like oil things you got to give
those up and when we come back I'm gonna
get a shark here's something to add to
your system so you can support healthy
blood pressure here after your listed
two dead doctors still live are the CBS
Radio Network with your host dr. Joel
Wallach
[Music]
imagine a rich decadent chocolate that's
actually good for you
young gemenese triple treat chocolate is
just that an antioxidant rich dark
chocolate complete with probiotics to
aid in proper digestion this all-natural
product contains no preservatives and
for those with dietary restrictions its
gluten-free dairy-free glycemic friendly
and kosher certified not only does
triple treat dark chocolate tastes
fantastic
it contains super antioxidant
blueberries to absorb free radicals with
an ORAC value of sixteen thousand nine
hundred and thirty six per piece triple
treat chocolate also contains a
proprietary blend of probiotics with
over 500 million live healthy bacteria
per 8 grams at the time of manufacture
with 80 percent reaching the intestines
which is much more than most live
culture yogurts if you'd like to learn
more about nutritional supplementation
call your local youngevity associate and
don't forget to ask about home-based
business opportunities hello Judy
Deville vez here if I could only afford
to get one product out of everything
that product would be the ultimate
classic it has the vitamins the minerals
the bio flavonoids it even has grapeseed
extract the one product that would give
you just about everything under the Sun
you would need for a perfect nutritional
program would be the ultimate classic by
the way people that are on the go it's
very very hard to take the liquids with
them when they go on their trip to get
their supplements in everyday well you
know something you can use the ultimate
daily tablets and the mineral capsules
when I'm going on a trip if I have
enough room I just take the two bottles
with me if not just use a little baggie
and take a couple of daily doses with
you it's very simple it's very easy
there's no mess no fuss no refrigeration
just take your capsules take your
tablets and you're finished for the day
to order these products call your local
youngevity distributor today you've
listed a physician and veterinarian dr.
Joel Wallach helped many people on the
dead doctors don't lie talk radio
program you've also heard hundreds of
people tell how dr. Wallach and
many products have changed their lives
if you're now convinced that dr. Wallach
is on to something and you want to try
your Japanese premium quality products
for yourself we could connect you with a
distributor that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at three one three four four
four 3463
that's three one three four four four
three four six three call right now and
leave your name telephone number or
email address and we'll see to it that
the right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
[Music]
work back with doctors don't lie on the
CBS radio network dr. Joel Wallach your
young duty nine o'clock you say Dan
Douglas right back to Virginians
Kathleen okay Shara sounds like camping
doing everything right here I wouldn't
be too upset about the 295 total
cholesterol that really means that
you're giving your brain what it needs
to stay right and you don't get Al's or
disease or low risk for Alexandra's ease
also you have plenty of Harmelin raw
material there so that's good and then
the fact that you have a elevated LDL
means you're eating too many
inflammatory things fried foods
vegetable oils salad dressings cooking
all those kind of things get rid of all
that sure what would you do for high
blood pressure how would you support a
sure I like suggest you take the
ultimate daily classic and the nice and
plus very good the opener daily classic
go ahead and take three of those tablets
price today those two bottles a month
and the ultimate nice and pledge to go
ahead and take one of those twice a day
take people they're gonna support
healthy blood pressure healthy blood
flow through even blocked arteries give
us a call every two weeks know what your
blood pressure is next time you go in
for cholesterol and your blood tests let
us know what that is okay we have time
for another one we sure do let's head to
Pennsylvania and Kathy Jerrod with dr.
Wallach my husband I met with you in
lancaster last month you showed us a
picture of Shara
just when to compliment you sure you
look wonderful my question is I have a
friend his little boy was diagnosed with
neutropenia and also was most recently
diagnosed with a weakening leg I'm a
youngevity distributor in you and other
associates have equipped us with tools
to become more knowledgeable through
webinars and so much more
I'm not really sure but he's pretty thin
he's about ten years old okay so that
would be probably right okay so he has a
weekend you said leg you didn't say legs
you got one leg one leg yes okay and
neutropenia can be due to a variety of
things but also he has osteoporosis the
bone marrow cavity can be filling up
with connective tissue and and the
production the white blood cells can be
reduced as a result are he just a fish
nutrients which required to make white
blood cells so char here's a kid weighs
somewhere between 70 and 100 pounds what
would you give him and what kind of dad
would you put him on
obviously I'd put him on a gluten-free
diet and I would get him on one I would
get him on one healthy bone and joint
pack which has the gluco gel and it also
has the calcium for the support all the
bones and joints and all that what would
you do the neutropenia the low low blood
what what what would you do to support
stem cell activity bone marrow I would
give him the M which he could take the
MRT Liam that would help anyone botany
March aliens that could take one or two
of those tablets twice a day you can
also a Shar said take one healthy bone
and joint pack that's going to support
means repair and the growth and puberty
stuff going on with this kid the buy
everything in half that one healthy
bones that wouldn't hurt to get in a
extra bottle of the so you have two
ounces a day the out your paycheck I see
effects and then give us call every
couple of weeks and any time he goes in
for another blood test but you want to
know more about that weakening leg it
could be a back problem it could be
other things we need to look you know I
mean it could be some more serious
things going with a brain spinal cord if
you a lot of stuff and so we needed some
follow-up every couple of weeks please
do that Kathy alright how much time we
have here I got about 60 seconds 60
seconds so I'm gonna go ahead and take
it remind everybody about this new CD a
stick of butter day keeps it back where
I'm very very excited about this new CD
because it really takes up we're dead
dogs don't lie left off and it is just
flying out here people are just loving
it it just I actually gave it as an
interview I actually gave the interview
in New York and they never had so many
calls in that radio station as when I
did that interview which became a stick
of butter day keeps the doctor way and
of course that's going to help reduce
the risk of heart disease yeah
and liver disease yeah and Alton disease
yeah and all kinds of stuff because that
that
failed theory the medical system that
cholesterol and set your fat cause
creditors he failed theory so don't
forget that stick of butter day keeps
the doctor way you want to listen to
that CD make sure everybody in your
household gets one start getting them
for the holidays make sure it's a
stocking stuffers everybody you want to
leave that with your tip at the
restaurant put your name and phone
number on it people will contact you I
need more information and help build
your youngevity business with DD DL dead
dogs a lie and a stick of butter a day
keeps back away
well thank you sh are super job as usual
thank you so much Duggan Samsa programs
out residual great questions and
testimonies today thank you so much
everybody god bless each and every one
of you god bless our troops godless or
Navy SEALs and god bless america
[Music]